okay so I kind of lied when I said that
we would never cover anymore all-new
all-different marvel stuff ah there are
still a few stories that I care about
and then I want to cover most notably
Thanos now anybody who's been reading
the Thanos solo series so far knows that
it is amazing it is insane and the
Thanos solo series always have been like
the jim Starlin run the first Thanos
solo run it was crazy
he fought Galactus to a standstill you
always find some pretty cool stuff just
because of the fact that Thanos is
literally just unbridled power I mean
it's crazy to see his character depict
it in such a way but the great thing
about this is that you know writer Jeff
Lemire really kind of turns those tables
on its head and so what we initially do
here is we pick up with the remnants of
the Black Order now here's the funny
thing the Black Order was this very
enigmatic group that had basically been
rolled into Jonathan Hickman's infinity
or been introduced you and Jonathan
Hickman's infinity as part of the lead
up to seeker wars as part of the whole
Avengers New Avengers run we don't
really know anything about the Black
Order I mean we know the consists of
like Proxima midnight and ebony maw and
you know Corvus glaive but for the most
part we don't really know anything about
that we don't know their origin stories
we don't really know where they came
from they're just there one day now the
biggest are really kind of the best
description that we get here is that the
Black Order was basically just
amalgamation of people who were either
vying for power or they were mercenaries
they were just you know hired guns
whatever the case may event but they
were all basically you know kind of
entranced or they were seduced by the
power and the money that danos promised
in exchange for their help and so they
all have their own little areas of
expertise but with regards to a host
Secret Wars landscape for the most part
Thanos had just kind of gone missing or
he had just sort of disappeared now we
know the reason why is because the fact
that Thanos had been banished from the
realm of mistress death and so during
the events of Secret Wars when he was
killed by God King doom he wasn't
technically killed because he couldn't
go to the realm of mistress death he'd
been banished from there and so what had
happened to him he was he was put
outside of all things in existence he
was literally in a void of nothingness
and so when Reed Richards took the power
of God King doom and when he recreated
the Marvel Universe
Thanos still existed outside of the
universe and even the multiverse now
eventually Thanos managed to find a way
back in and that led into the pre Lu to
Civil War - but during the
time where Thanos had basically just
been absent where he was just kind of
existing out in the void of nothingness
the former members of his Black Order
took this opportunity to basically
achieve their own goals now different
members did this different ways but in
the case of Corvus glaive he basically
took over control of the black quadrant
which was this area of the universe that
Thanos had basically taken and made his
own little section his own little base
of operations so to speak now the funny
thing about this was that Thanos had
basically ruled in fear I mean that's
what we expect from Thanos you know he
rules by fear either you can bow or you
can be destroyed Corvus glaive took a
far more diplomatic approach I mean he
was more ordered he was more rigid he
was more structured and his whole empire
ran pretty well the problem with this is
that following the events of unworthy
Thor where Thanos had basically walked
away from you know the idea of trying to
capture the hammer of Thor following
those events and going into right now
with regards to his own solo series
phantos has returned to the black
quadrant only to find out that Corvus
glaive has tried to take up his place as
king as ruler of this area so again it's
really kind of cool because what ends up
happening here is that knows immediately
overpowers Corvus glaive and then
basically tells Corvus glaive either you
can kill yourself or I will kill you but
if I kill you I'll make it last weeks
whereas you can kill yourself and it'll
be done and over right now so again
there's really no way out for Corvus
glaive here and this was really kind of
like Jeff Lemire really sort of wrapping
up these loose ends these loose hot
threads that have been left hanging at
the end of Secret Wars with regards
these characters because you know of
course as we know Marvel failed in its
entirety and did not reboot so what we
end up doing from here is we basically
pick up with the champion of the
universe now the champion of the
universe is actually a pretty
interesting character this guy's name is
Trico Slattery's and the champion of the
universe really kind of had like these
off and on appearances over the course
of Marvel Comics he was always a
background character now really his
biggest claim to fame or at least as far
as I'm concerned his biggest claim to
fame came in the form of him possessing
the power gym one of the Infinity stones
that that has had captured during the
infinity quest as a lead-up to the
original Infinity Gauntlet story but the
champion of the universe is basically
just a guy that travels around the
universe challenging himself to
different fights fighting different
opponents you know going against you
know all different manner of life
whether it's these very primitive beasts
that are existing around a landscape or
whether it's you know people who
consider themselves to be prize fighters
in some capacity a champion goes through
and fights them all and does the best he
can and taking them all out but what we
enough fight
out here is that Treecko has basically
been sent by you know some unnamed
person for the purpose of acquiring star
fox now star fox also known as eros is
actually the brother of Thanos and this
really kind of brings in the nature of
fan OHS himself at his core and this is
gonna blow your mind
Thanos is effectively human he really is
pretty much human and that's what really
kind of like bond you know baffles
people because they're like Thanos is
human yeah Thanos descends from humanity
the way it works we've talked about this
before but we'll talk about it for all
new folks the way it worked is that you
had three groups you had the deviants
who were basically these really evil
twisted you know beings that lived
underground uh you had the Eternals who
were more like angels and then you had
normal humans that had their genes
modified in such a capacity that
superpowers would begin to emerge some
fifteen thousand years later or their
genes were modified in the capacity that
they would basically be allowed to
develop superheroes since the reason why
Bruce Banner became the Incredible Hulk
after being blasted with gamma radiation
as opposed to simply just dying you know
so because of that some of the Eternals
had basically left earth and taken up
residence on Saturn's moon Titan now the
reason why this matters is because the
entirety of the human genome had been
modified by the Celestials which meant
that Eternals had deviant genes devious
had eternal genes humans had a mixture
of both now for the most part they
always stayed separated you had the
Eternals you had the deviants and he had
the baseline humans but those Eternals
who had taken up residence on titan
still maintained some of these deviant
genes now as they procreated as they
went on as they you know gave birth and
had offspring and so forth for the most
part they were just giving birth to
Eternals but then Thanos was born and
Thanos had a deviant gene which is why
he looks the way he does that's why he
looks you know purple with the
weird-looking scroll champ he's
basically a deviant but at his core he
descends from humanity now the idea here
is that because of the fact that you
know it's kind of the whole origin of
Thanos his father was a guy named mentor
who basically ran the entire you know I
guess group of Eternals on Titan and his
brother was irrespective history for you
but the fact remains here that what
we're basically told or at least what
eros is told by champion is that Thanos
is alive and well and that the goal of
eros and and champion is to take out
take out Thanos now of course we end up
finding the reason why this is being
done is because they've all basically
been brought together
by Fame and the funny thing about this
is that Thane has effectively lost his
power we'll talk about him a little bit
more here in a second but he's
effectively lost his power but he's
being greeted by mistress death not only
that where mistress death basically kind
of goads him into the idea of trying to
attack and kill Thanos the initial
response of Thames is we can't do that
Thanos is basically a god there's no way
to really kill Thanos but mistress death
counters and says no that's not true
Thanos is basically dying now with
regards to the character of Thane I
wanted to kind of you know wait a second
to get to this with regards to the
character of Thane he was a character
that was again introduced as part of
infinity the sort of winding down point
for a lot of the Marvel cosmic landscape
and so on but the idea of Thane is that
he is one of a multitude of offspring of
fantasy and Thanos had basically been
traveling around the cosmos killing off
every member of the offspring that he
had every single child he'd ever created
he wouldn't killed them all off
eventually this led him to earth where
he encountered the Inhumans while
looking for Thane now this actually led
to this amazing battle between Thanos
and Black Bolt kind of was so cool like
like Thanos is asking Black Bolt he was
like where's my son and like Black Bolt
won't tell him so he's like fine keep
your secrets carry them with you to the
grave and I smashed his head into the
ground it's amazing it's like this
amazing thing ultimately what we end up
doing here is we actually transition to
a place called a planet Nuala now this
is not wildly significant here it's
really just kind of Jeff Lemire giving
us an indication of all the different
forms of life that exist around the
universe but the planet Nuala is very
much a monk-like planet in the sense
that its inhabitants only really no
peace there they kind of commune with
nature they're you know very very
peaceful they're a lot like hippies but
they also study you know medicine and
different things like that
there are their knowledge of treatment
of diseases and illnesses and so on is
really the most respected throughout the
universe is the one place that virtually
every single alien race goes to whenever
it is they need to be treated for any
particular illness or figure out what it
is that's ailing them the problem with
this is that Thanos arrives on the scene
and of course Thanos being displeased at
the fact that he's dying and that none
of these members of this race are able
to give him any answers in terms of
what's killing him or how to treat it he
basically just obliterates them all so
again it's really showing it's kind of
like this ruthless nature of Panos and
how cruel he is you know in the fact
that he just doesn't care about
destroying anybody so long as he gets
the information that he seeks now at
this point we transition over to the
introduction of nebula and that's really
something that i hope you guys notice
here is it's really kind of like
a lot of these traditional characters
from the Thanos landscape being
reintroduced being brought back in and
brought into the fray of whatever it is
it's gonna happen to Thanos now of
course nebula he's basically in the
message is doing whatever is that she
does like stealing stuff it's just
nebula doing crime stuff because your
nebula that's what you do when your
nebula but she's basically caught by uh
by Star Fox who in turn says look you
have to come with us we're gonna be
going on this mission in order to
basically meet with our benefactor and
try to take down phantoms now of course
from here we transition with Thanos over
to his father mentor that's the other
cool thing about this as a Jeff Lemire
kind of gives us this big you know tour
of the whole different landscape of the
Thanos you know mythology in the Thanos
race and I guess you know the whole life
cycle that he has and so on but we
basically transition over to mentor
again mentor having been you know the
the father of Thanos know the reason why
there's so much animosity between these
two is for two main reasons the first is
because of the fact that as a child
Thanos first encountered mistress deaths
you took a very particular interest in
him just because of the fact that his
physical appearance made him a outcast
to the larger you know eternal society
and a lot of the children that he went
to school with who basically teased and
they give him a hard time
mistress death used this as a way to go
the darker side of Thanos which
eventually led him to basically killing
all the kids who had given him a hard
time at the same time Santos basically
left his planet you know does kind of
explored the universe eventually came
back and obliterated the entirety of the
moon of Titan killing virtually every
single member of the eternal race except
for you know his his father and his
brother
of course Thanos had previously killed
his mother and so because of that his
life is mired in death and destruction
and the entire empire that his father
had had led that his father had formed
had come crashing down because of the
actions of Thanos himself and so what
this does is it creates a lot of
animosity between the two and it's
always been that way
and we keep in mind that US has always
been a being a conquest the cosmic queue
the Infinity stones again it's really
kind of cool with regards to this whole
little tidbit of storytelling because
ultimately you know he asked his father
you have to examine me you have to
figure out what's going on I know you
don't want to but I also know that we're
on a Shiar base and I know that there
are a lot of scientists and families
here and if you do not do what I tell
you to I will kill them all and so again
he basically just kind of blackmails him
into helping out Faneuil so now what
this reveals is that thanasis cells are
basically breaking down on the genetic
level he's effectively dying of cancer
and again it's kind of an interesting
scenario because that's what killed
marvel and it makes sense really for
Thanos to be dying of cancer just
because of the fact but he's dealt with
this before in the form of Marvel who
could arguably be considered his most
notable enemy in the Marvel cosmology
prior to his death in 1984 again that's
going all the way back to the 70s and
80s oh really not very many people read
or even care about those comics anymore
but there's still a lot of history there
in terms of the life and times of Thanos
now because of the fact that there's
really no cure for thinness himself he's
basically dying he effectively just kind
of lashes out and kills his father in
the process so again you know what this
does is it leads to a direct conflict
between Thanos and the Shiar Imperial
Guard and we'll get around to them here
in a second but jumping back to to
Thames you know Jenny back to these
these various guys here what we end up
finding out is that Thames has
effectively formed a plan the Thane
himself can't really pull it off Thames
kind of looks around and says look you
know my goal is to take down Thanos but
I can't do it on my own and so I'm
effectively bringing you guys in nebula
you've got a grudge with Thanos you know
when Thanos had the Infinity stone you
appeared to him beforehand and said oh
I'm your your granddaughter because
nebula was coveting power only for
Thanos to find out that nebula was lying
and basically twisted her into this
weird you know mutilated little thing
and just kind of had her for raiding
around here and there of course the
Infinity Gauntlet was a way for Marvel
to kind of correct that and for a nebula
to go back to the way she was before but
her mind was broken it was shattered
that's why in a lot of ways with the
Infinity Gauntlet nebula was more
dangerous than Thanos was the champion
of the universe prides himself on
engaging in conflicts but well actually
find out there's a little more history
between him and Fame and it's initially
led on and then of course you know
starfox being the brother of Thanos it's
really kind of a making the case saying
look it's your responsibility to step up
here it's your brother that's running to
the universe and kind of ripping things
up now with regards to the to the Shiar
Imperial Guard this conflict between
Thanos is actually it goes the way that
it shouldn't go the Shia Imperial Guard
really launches their attacks in three
waves when it comes to Thanos now
normally they don't do this they just
kind of show up and they subdue whoever
it is they're facing off against but as
Thanos and so the first wave comes in
the form of really kind of like a
physical attack so people who have
super-strength the people who have you
know durability and so on and so forth
the second wave comes and you know
energy attacks and the third wave comes
in beams of just incredible power but
the thing to keep in mind here is that
none of these guys should be successful
Thanos if he was at full strength would
easily overtake every single one of
these guys without even thinking about
it and so again it's kind of a really
a moment here now of course where he's
able to at least where it seems like the
Shia and period is starting to take over
him once he's able to muster himself
Thanos immediately comes back with one
heck of an attack and begins just
obliterating every last one of these
guys now he doesn't really kill a whole
lot of them
he just subdues them in the extreme I
mean I think maybe one or two of them
died but for the most part it's just
beating the absolute crap out of them
before the scenario gets to the point
where people are gonna start dying we
end up having gladiator intervene now of
course gladiator was previously the head
of the Shiar Imperial Guard he's one of
the middie in ER many iterations that
Marvel has of Superman within their own
comic books but gladiator is basically
the best and strongest of all the races
that make up the Shiar empire and
because of this you know as time
progressed he was basically elevated to
the position of its magistrates meaning
he's basically the one running the show
now he's a leader of the Shiar empire
but because of the fact that Thanos is
so powerful and because of the fact that
Thanos cannot be subdued so easily this
leads to gladiator showing up here now
this begs the question what would happen
if a full power gladiator faced off
against a full powered Thanos and I'm
sure has happened in the comics before
uh but I can't remember off top my head
when it's ever happened but with Thanos
basically being the ill with him
effectively dying it's reduced his power
by a pretty good margin and so what this
did is it basically resulted in him
really just kind of losing you know this
conflict and basically being taken
prisoner by the Shiar Imperial Guard now
at this point we transition over to the
fallout of theme and the reason why is
because of the fact that following the
events of infinity and even going into
like you know black vortex and so on and
so forth they need kind of waxed him
wing Marvel in a lot of ways was trying
to build up the character of Fame and
try to reintroduce him as like the new
Thanos effectively the problem with this
is a Thanos was so rooted in Marvel's
cosmic landscape he had so many just
massive crossover stories and he'd been
such an intrinsic part of the Marvel
cosmology you couldn't just get rid of
Thanos it would be like killing off
Galactus he can't kill off Galactus
permanently he's just gotta be there
he's just an intrinsic part of the
Marvel cosmology just like getting rid
of spider-man or getting rid of Captain
America's Steve Rogers you know
regardless of what form they take they
always have to be there because they're
just an intrinsic part of the Marvel
landscape now with regards to Thane what
had happened is that he's basically an
inhuman it really just kind of a result
of of him undergoing exposure to the
Terrigen mist but what happens is he's
basically got two different
forms of energy he's got one power that
will literally just kill whoever it is
us around and the view decides to invoke
this energy it'll kill everybody in his
immediate vicinity the other power will
encase individuals in amber and this was
really just kind of the role that he
played during the events of infinity now
in this instance he's still with ebony
MA and this guy is still basically
training you know training fan on his
powers this of course all takes place
about eight months ago but the fact
remains here that Thane had to wear this
sort of energy suit they would basically
regulate his powers if he didn't he
would lose control and it would just
result in people dying or being encased
in amber all over the place and so of
course under the tutelage of ebony maw
what this tells us is that immediately
after the events of secret Wars but
before all-new all-different marvel
officially started that fame had
basically gone through and conquered the
black quadrant but the idea was that
Corvus glaive had showed up with the
intention of taking it away from from
Thane himself now
what did of happening here is Corvus
glaive invoked a group called the coven
now this is a wholly new creation by
Jeff Lemire they've never existed before
I've never ever heard of them they're
apparently a coven of three witches that
they have the most knowledge of magic or
they're the oldest magic in existence
how far their power stretches we don't
really know what we do know is they had
enough power to effectively strip Thane
of all of his powers so he basically is
just a guy running around with no power
whatsoever and what this did is it
allowed Corvus glaive to step in and
basically take the black quadrant for
himself and that's how Corvus glaive
came to be the one in charge the black
quadrant at the beginning of this story
now following the defeat of Fame he was
effectively taken prisoner this kind of
throne in one of you know Corvus glaive
prison cells and he was just basically
held there until the champion showed up
now why the champions there we don't
know presumably he was fighting somebody
or he was just captured or whatever the
case may be but he was basically just
kind of thrown in the same cell but a
kind of Brotherhood or I guess a kind of
camaraderie began to develop between the
two now of course this eventually led to
Corvus glaive realizing that their
prison sentence was not nearly as harsh
as it was supposed to be which
eventually led to thane basically being
removed and then thrown into solitary
confinement but in his solitary
confinement he was met with the arrival
of mistress death now this is the nature
of mistress death when it comes to
Marvel comics and Thor Ragnarok the
movie Thor 3 really begs the question
what form mistress death will take I
haven't read too much into it I don't
know if Feige or anybody has said that
mistress death will actually be there
but you have a being named hell
and you have a being named mistress deaf
now as far as I'm aware Marvel's never
really reconciled these two beings if
like hella is an aspect of mistress
death or hella is a wholly separate
entity I would imagine she's just an
aspect of mistress death but regardless
mistress death is the one official being
when it comes to death when it comes to
all things that die you know during the
events of Rockets during the lead-up to
Secret Wars for example when the
Beyonder showed up in the main Marvel
Universe and the multiverse and we're
killing off all the cosmic entities the
only one that didn't die was mistress
death because she's the representation
of death so long as there's life she's
supposed to be the one that just you
know sees all those things being killed
now this also brings into the equation
the idea that she can be killed we saw
that in the cancerverse you know when
she was basically destroyed and it led
to a universe where nobody died
everybody just lived forever and you
know things just kind of got out of
control and just sort of went awry but
the fact remains here that with the
character of mistress death she's very
manipulative she's very duplicitous the
way that she's interacting with Thane is
exactly the way the she interacted with
Thanos when the two of them first
encountered one another its promises of
glory promises of conquest promises of
love and romance you know and pleasures
of the flesh and all those different
kinds of things and so because of that
ultimately Thane is basically swayed to
her cause just totally immersed in this
whole thing of you will overcome your
father one day you know you will be the
one to kill thanos you will form a
kingdom of your own and all that kind of
good stuff and so the result is that he
actually frees champion in the process
which tells us how the two of them came
together now of course you're here it is
a matter of can they actually pull it
off and what we end up finding out here
is that because Thane is effectively
powerless he needs a way in which to
basically fight against his father
Thanos and be successful in the first
place and so what they end up doing is
they actually end up invading a ship
that belongs to a guy named Terrax the
tamer and now Terrax the tamer is an old
character I mean he goes back to 1979
with Fantastic Four number 211 I think
it is um his name is actually Tyra
that's really what his name is he comes
from a planet called Burge or something
like that but he was basically a Herald
of Galactus at one point in time now the
whole motivation was at the time
Galactus had looked at like the Silver
Surfer and he had looked at like Frankie
Rey you know and he looked at all these
different servants that he had but the
idea was that his heralds always
rebelled against him because they came
from beings that had moral imperatives
they believed in right and wrong what
Galactus needed was a person who was a
moral and so we actually had the fan
for defeat Tyros and then in turn mate
Tyrus his uh his Herald and then Tyrus
basically rebuilt like they all do and
they became Terrax the tamer in this
instance the arrival on tear axes ship
comes by way of the fact that Terrax
possesses a weapon that Fame needs in
order to be able to defeat his father
now again this invokes a lot of the cool
elements of individual characters when
it comes to nebula for example being one
of the most dangerous women in the
universe champion kind of be in the
powerhouse and fame being the brains
behind the operation starfox is a guy
whose silver tongue can talk him out of
virtually anything I so he's really just
here to kind of keep you know Terrax
preoccupied but then basically reveals
hey look the reason why I'm here is to
literally just distract you so the rest
of my team can access the weapon that
you're holding and what we end up
finding out is that the weapon that
Terrax is holding is the phoenix egg
essentially the Phoenix force waiting
for a new house now from here this
really kind of brings in the idea of how
we reconcile two different things
because in the Mighty Thor the Asgard
Shiar war the unworthy four and Jane
Foster Thor faced off against the
Phoenix force and what ended up
happening as Quentin choir became the
new host and so what seems to be going
on here is that these two stories seem
to be contradicting each other which
really begs the question where does this
take place exactly how does this happen
does this story take place long before
the events of unworthy Thor in which
case everything that we see with Thanos
in that story is part of unworthy Thor
basically comes after all this it really
kind of begs the question of continuity
and that's one of the issues the
marvel's kind of running into here at
the moment is that their continuity
issues are kind of wreaking havoc
they're not nearly as organized you know
as DC is for example with regards to
rebirth but the fact remains here the
Thanos effectively breaks out of his
prison I mean there's really not a lot
to go on there he breaks out of his cell
just kind of wrecks a whole bunch of
people and then takes off and goes back
to his home the black quadrant only for
him to realize that basically Thane had
overpowered Terrax the tamer and in turn
returned home with the intention of
killing Thanos now the funny thing about
this is that again he's constantly
goaded by mistress death and this is
really the most human that we see that
owes in this particular story Thanos
effectively tells Thane everything she
promises you is a lot like everything
she says she will give you is a lie and
that's true you know Thanos learned that
from his own experienced mistress death
lies she manipulates she cheats she
tricks she does whatever it is that she
needs to do in order to achieve her own
goal and the response of Thanos is she
will lead you down the prim
path if you let her you have to free
yourself you know from this influence
that she has on you and stand on your
own two feet now of course being
enamored by mistress death ultimately
Thane decides against his father and in
doing so the presumption is that he
kills Thanos but a fact a nose is not
actually dead instead Thane basically
takes up the throne of his father
declaring himself king Thane and we find
out that instead of killing Thanos Vayne
had actually made Thanos mortal would
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]